l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
politique du dimanche soir sur radio
sensations diffuses et aussi sur tv 118
épisode 208 mon invité ce soir et le
maire modem de vie pour jean baptiste à
monique
[Musique]
les politiques
jean baptiste à monique bonsoir bonsoir
quand vous êtes le maire modem de
villepreux et vice-président à saint
quentin en yvelines en charge des
transports et des mobilités vous êtes
aussi le président du modem dans les
yvelines élu maire en 2020 à villepreux
vous avez déjà affrontées à l'échelon
local la crise sanitaire cette semaine
s'est tenue le 103e congrès des maires
de france c'est votre premier congrès de
la haye mais en tant que mère c'était un
moment important pour vous cette semaine
oui c'est un moment important je pense
que c'est un moment important pour
l'ensemble des maires de france et de
navarre comme on dit déjà parce que il
n'y a pas pu l'édition n'a pas pu se
tenir l'année dernière en raison de la
crise sanitaire vous l'avez évoqué et
puis pour les jeunes mères ou moins
jeunes mais en tout cas pour ceux qui
ont été élus pour la première fois en
2020 c'était un moment important un
moment par un moment important parce que
on n'a pas eu l'occasion d'échanger on
n'a pas eu l'occasion de se retrouver à
la fois avec nos collègues maires du
territoire mais aussi d'ailleurs mais
aussi avec nos partenaires ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien à nos côtés
pour la réussite de nos projets dans nos
communes que ce soit des institutionnels
que ce soit des partenaires privés donc
c'était important parce qu'il ya
l'aspect congrès mais il ya l'aspect
salon ça nous permet aussi d'aller voir
tous ses partenaires qu'on n'a pas
forcément le temps de voir au quotidien
dans l'eau dans nos mandats et puis
évidemment il ya eu une séance de
clôture qui était attendu et importante
à la fois avec le discours de notre
nouveau président david lisnard qui a
été qui a été élu et que je tiens à
féliciter et puis discours du président
de la république avant justement
l'élection présidentielle donc c'était
un discours qui était attendu mais c'est
un moment fort et j'ai eu plaisir à y
être
fière en france en tout cas de l'ordre
lors de lors du discours du président et
puis un petit peu avant justement pour
échanger avec l'ensemble des partenaires
comme ça on va encore parler de l'aspect
politique avec le discours du président
notamment de la république mais sur
l'aspect salon justement vous reveniez
qu'est ce que vous avez pu voir que vous
avez évoqué quels sujets vous avez pu
échanger allez j'y suis allé à plusieurs
titres on en reparlera peut-être mais
étant membre de l'association des
petites villes de france il y avait
plusieurs partenaires que je souhaitais
voir je voulais voir l' agence nationale
de la cohésion des territoires voir le
serena en tout cas voire tous ses
partenaires encore une fois qui nous
permettent de porter des projets dans
nos communes avec ma casquette de
vice-président aussi aux transports et
aux mobilités à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines j'avais à
coeur de voir certains opérateurs
certains transporteurs donc sa salle pu
aussi être l'occasion de le faire et
puis plus généralement
passée voir encore une fois tout ce
qu'on n'a pas le temps de voir parce
qu'on est pris par nos fonctions on est
pris par le tout venant et la gestion
aussi comme vous l'avez dit en année
coville qui est assez particulière ça
permet de voilà ça permet de continuer à
créer des synergies avec avec l'ensemble
de ces acteurs qui travaillent avec les
collectivités dans les maires ont élu
david lisnard mer et l'air de cannes à
la tête de l'association des maires de
france vous souteniez vous le candidat
udi de saut le maire de sceaux philippe
laurent tout à fait sais-tu c'est un
échec pour la majorité présidentielle
cette défaite non mais je crois
d'ailleurs que il ya eu cette caricature
faite de philippe laureau comme quoi il
serait ou candidat de la florida de la
majorité présidentielle non ce n'est pas
parce qu'il avait des mères qui sont
dans une démarche constructive et
positive tout en étant exigeante tout en
étant exigeant lors des marches est
exigeante à l'égard de l'exécutif que ça
faisait de la liste de philippe laurent
une liste de la majorité présidentielle
je crois que ce n'était pas le cas en
tout cas le résultat est ce qu'il est
moi je regrette évidemment pas mon choix
je souhaite évidemment bon courage à
david lisnard danser dans ses nouvelles
fonctions qui vont être elle aussi
exigeante en tout cas l'essentiel je
croyais préserver c'est l'unité des
maires dans sa diversité et maintenant
il faut qu'on avance tous ensemble et je
crois que c'est de bon augure puisque
finalement le bureau tel qu'il a été
composé va rassembler l'ensemble des
tendances des maires qui s'expriment sur
le paysage politique français donc non
je pense que c'est une association
maintenant qu'ils les conditions sont
réunies pour que l'on fonctionne bien
tous ensemble dans le président de la
république emmanuel macron est arrivé en
2010 est sans avoir été auparavant un
élu de terrain ça lui a été souvent
reproché par les maires il a souhaité
initier une nouvelle vague de la société
civile et s'est attiré la méfiance des
élus locaux au début du mandat qui
étaient eux un puits en planter depuis
beaucoup pour beaucoup depuis des années
dans leur territoire les relations ont
souvent été compliquées entre le
président la république et les maires en
2017 emmanuel macron s'était d'ailleurs
fait huer au congrès de la mf en 2018 il
ne s'y était pas rendu puis est venu
ensuite la crise des gilets jaunes le
grand débat le président avait alors
décidé plusieurs fois de s'adresser
directement aux aux élus locaux au mieux
à même peut-être de comprendre la colère
des français les maires ont aussi
démontré leur importance on a déjà
évoqué lors de la crise sanitaire
notamment lors de l'ouverture des écoles
par exemple aujourd'hui beaucoup de
candidats à la présidentielle c'est de
séduire les maires ils ont raison de le
faire
je sais pas si c'est une démarche de
séduction en tout cas moi je suis plutôt
satisfait de cette prise de conscience
et je cible pas le président de la
république par rapport à ça mais on ne
construit pas la république qui ont
construit pas la france de demain sans
les élus locaux et sont les mères on l'a
dit tout le monde le dit la commune est
la cellule de base de la démocratie
c'est la vida c'est l'échelon de
proximité par excellence c'est là qu'on
arrive à sentir le pouls du terrain
finalement je ne dis pas que les élus
nationaux les députés ne sont pas en
prise avec les réalités locales loin de
là mais c'est vrai que nous nous sommes
confrontés au quotidien aux anges et ou
aux problématiques du quotidien
justement de nos administrés et donc et
donc des français
pour ce qui est du président de la
république moi j'étais très satisfait
par son par son discours hier il l'a lui
même reconnu il a il a employé ce terme
il a dit je crois qu'il ya eu peut-être
des incompréhensions des mépris sur le
début de mandat on lui a reproché je
trouvais qu'il l'a souligné avec un
trait d'humour qui dont il a lui-même le
secret mais qui était plutôt le bienvenu
il disait on m'a reproché de ne pas être
maire mais je crois que en ce moment à
l'heure où justement on revendique un
peu l'héritage du général de gaulle le
général de gaulle lui même n'a pas
mr est donc c'est le cas de plusieurs
présidents de la république dont je
crois que ça c'est un faux procès non
moi en revanche je crois que l'élément
déclencheur et vous l'avez évoqué en
tout cas le tournant c'est le grand
débat au moment où il lance ce grand
débat au moment où il lance cette idée
de revenir sur le terrain d'aller voir
les maires et de repartir des communes
pour ses fameux cahiers de doléances 1
qui avait été qui avait été proposé à ce
moment là on est au moment de la crise
aussi des gilet jaune on n'est pas
encore dans la crise sanitaire je crois
qu'on a on a retrouvé un exécutif qui
avait à coeur de fonctionner et
travailler avec les élus locaux ensuite
il ya eu évidemment plusieurs avancées
législatives et plusieurs actions
gouvernementales qu'on pourra saluer je
crois qu'il ya encore un chemin à
parcourir moi ce que je note c'est que
la confiance a été rétablie depuis un
petit moment déjà je pense que ça c'est
la deuxième partie du quinquennat je
trouve aussi que aujourd'hui et le
président l'a dit hier et vous l'avez
souligné les maires ont été en première
ligne pendant les crises et notamment la
crise sanitaire dont il a exprimé hier
en tout cas lors du congrès toute sa
gratitude envers les mères et il nous a
détaillé sa méthode en tout cas ce que
lui pensait être une bonne méthode et
une feuille de route si il devait être
réélu mais aussi surtout sur la fin du
quinquennat pour qu'on travaille tous
ensemble à la réussite du bateau france
donc moi je trouve que c'était un
discours plein de bon sens rassembleur
évidemment avec un bilan à défendre je
crois qu'il était dans son rôle et puis
sur le fond peut-être qu'on y reviendra
dans l'interview mais moi je je crois
que ce n'est pas une question de
séduction c'est vraiment une question de
culture est une question de d'impératifs
qui a été bien saisi de dire que au
regard des enjeux qui sont devant nous
on ne pourra pas opposé l'état central à
aux collectivités il faut évidemment
qu'on travaille main dans la main et je
pense que c'est ce qui est fait depuis
un certain temps déjà alors cette
semaine à la mf un mot est revenu assez
souvent c'est le mot décentralisation
parce qu'il faut aller dans ce sens
selon vous alors
je vais peut-être est un peu en décalage
par rapport à mai à mes collègues maires
je pense que oui je pense
qu'effectivement on a besoin davantage
de décentralisation mais on ne peut pas
reprocher à l'état et au gouvernement en
place de ne pas être plus loin dans la
décentralisation et ça a été rappelé par
le président lui-même la première le
premier souhait des élus locaux dès le
début du quinquennat macron c'était de
dire monsieur le président on a eu la
loi nôtre on a eu la loi map tam on a eu
le redécoupage des régions on a eu
toutes ces choses là sous le quinquennat
de françois hollande qui nous ont
apporté de l'instabilité on a besoin
d'une pause surtout on a besoin d'une
pause ne revenait pas avec des grandes
lois de décentralisation et en cela le
bilan était tenu il ya eu des avancées
sur lesquels on pourra peut-être revenir
mais il ya eu des avancées il ya eu des
programmes je pense à petite ville de
demain action coeur de ville je pense à
la création de la haine c'est et je
pense à toutes ces choses là qui ont
permis de faire avancer la cause des
collectivités et notamment leur donner
les moyens porter leurs projets
oui on a besoin en revanche de
réaffirmer les libertés locales
moi j'ai soutenu la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation à partir du moment où
elles étaient compensées néanmoins ça
pose effectivement des questions de
levier pour les collectivités on parle
de l'autonomie financière on parle de
l'autonomie fiscale c'est effectivement
des sujets sur lesquels il va falloir
qu'on ait des réponses dans les
prochains mois et on l'espère dans le
prochain quinquennat donc on va
continuer à apporter cette cette parole
mais j'y prendrai toute ma part
notamment dans les différentes
associations dans lesquelles je peux je
peut siéger mais je crois qu'il faut
être vigilant sur le tout
décentralisation moi je suis
décentralisateur c'est la fibre aussi du
mouvement démocrate et l'héritage qu'on
a on est évidemment pour la
décentralisation mais je crois qu'il
faut être vigilant à ce que ça
s'articule bien avec un autre impératif
à mon sens ce qui est tout aussi
important qui est l'impératif d'une
bonne déconcentration on a aussi besoin
d'un état fort dans nos territoires et
je crois que c'est peut-être là où ça
pêche aujourd'hui c'est le rapport entre
les collectivités et l'administration
centrale moi je trouve qu'au niveau des
préfectures on a des préfets qui fondent
et qui font un travail remarquable mais
qui sont parfois un peu
eux mêmes pris entre le marteau et
l'enclume parce qu'on a des décisions
centrales ou des lourds dure dix
lourdeurs administratives en terme de
deux procédures qui viennent un peu
parasiter ce qui a pu être décidée par
le politique donc je pense qu'il faut
avancer sur tous ces sujets là
en revanche oui la décentralisation il
faudra peut-être une loi sur un second
quinquennat mais moi j'attends déjà la
loi 3ds je pense qu'il ya déjà des
mesures importantes qui qui sont qui
sont dans ce texte porté par jacqueline
gourault justement on va on va en parler
tout de suite c'est donc la loi 3ds un
projet de loi qui concerne la
décentralisation
la 3ds ça veut dire loi de
déconcentration décentralisation
différenciation puis plus simplification
alors l'idée majeure de ce projet de loi
c'est que l'état puisse expérimenter
l'utilisation de ses propres compétences
par les collectivités territoriales car
c'est une bonne idée ce genre
d'expérimentations louise notre honneur
c'était initialement le projet de loi 4d
et puis on s'est rendu compte que
finalement c'était plus simple que le
dernier des qui voulait dire des
complexification pas 100 simplifications
n'était voilà un exemple typique de ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur non
c'est une loi évidemment qui fait sens
qui est porté par par jacqueline
gourault munissent de la cohésion des
territoires modem effectivement avec ce
l'attachement qu'on lui connaît et on ne
pourra pas lui reprocher d'être une
ministre hors sol quand on connaît son
parcours maire président de présidents
d'intercommunalités et vice-présidente
du sénat par la suite une femme
politique pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration je trouve que ce texte est
équilibré évidemment il n'a pas vocation
à répondre à toutes à tous les à toutes
les problématiques il ya eu un texte
avant qui a été qui a été voté qui celui
de la loi engagement et proximité qui
venait aussi sécurisé quelque part les
élus locaux dans leurs fonctions et qui
apportaient certaine souplesse ce texte
là vous l'avez dit c'est la possibilité
d'expérimenter et il ya une expression
qu emploie souvent la ministre et je la
partage c'est aussi des dans l'idée du
du cousu main c'est de trouver des
solutions concrètes en fonction de la
réalité des territoires la
différenciation ce n'est ce n'est rien
d'autre que cela c'est de regarder
quelle est la réalité sur un territoire
et faire en sorte que la loi que les
textes que les programmes qui doivent
s'appliquer sur ce territoire puisse
tenir compte évidemment des enjeux et
des problématiques qui sont bien
spécifiques donc ça je crois que ça va
dans le bon sens moi ce que je retiens
surtout en tant qu' en tant que maire
pour être confronté à cette
problématique là c'est les avancées
qui ils sont inscrits sur la loi sru sur
le logement social on veut tous il faut
que ce soit très clair il n'y a pas un
maire en france qui ne souhaitent pas
participer à cet effort de solidarité de
construction de logement social quand on
sait qu'aujourd'hui en ile de france il
faudrait qu'on construise 300 mille
logements par an pour pouvoir répondre à
la demande on voit bien que
effectivement on ne peut pas juste faire
l'autruche et dire que l'on ne
construira pas néanmoins on est dans une
certaine schizophrénie aujourd'hui
puisque nous les maires nous sommes
confrontés à des impératifs aussi
écologiques et environnementaux que nous
défendons et je suis le premier à
inscrire par exemple des objectifs de 0
artificialisation des sols dans mon pays
à l'ue et j'engage la révision
actuellement mais
conjugués l'arrêt de l'étalement urbain
la préservation de l'environnement quand
on a plus de foncier etc on dit qu'il
faut continuer à construire du logement
social il faut qu'on nous dise comment
on fait et c'est là où la
différenciation est intéressante et sur
le logement social ce que dit cette loi
c'est que l'objectif des 25 % à horizon
2025 on va nous donner un peu plus de
temps pour le faire le texte a été
discuté au sénat pour le moment il ya eu
des avancées dont certains que je salue
qui ont été apportées par les sénateurs
notamment sur ce plan là on verra
comment le texte évolué à l'assemblée
nationale en tout cas c'est pas un petit
texte contrairement à ce qui a pu être
dit c'est pas un texte qui a pour
ambition de révolutionner la
décentralisation et fonctionnement des
colites et territoriales c'est un texte
qui a été construit en partenariat avec
les élus locaux et les associations
d'élus locaux et je pense qu'il va dans
le bon sens je pense qu'il va nous
apporter un petit peu plus de souplesse
et encore une fois qui va finalement
apporter des solutions en fonction des
réalités du terrain c'est une réforme
qui revient sur la table pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est le retour de la
réforme du conseiller territorial qui a
été donc voté en 2010 son quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande qui a
été ensuite élu président en 2012 na na
pas appliquer cette réforme aujourd'hui
plusieurs candidats appellent à la
mettre en oeuvre donc les conseillers
départementaux siégeraient aussi à
l'assemblée régionale si cette réforme
était la mise en place que pensez vous
de celle ci moi j'y suis favorable
d'ailleurs on avait une proposition
similaire porté par le modem il ya déjà
quelques années maintenant je crois même
qu'on avait pris position en faveur de
cette proposition justement je je je
sais pas si ce sera vraiment le sujet
prioritaire
en terme de collectif pour les
collectivités territoriales sur sur les
prochains mois et sur les prochaines
années parce que finalement le
conseiller territorial il pose la
question de l'organisation territoriale
donc il faut qu'on rouvre le débat moi
je suis pas contre mais qu'est-ce qu'on
supprime parce que finalement la
question ça va être ça en ile de france
at on besoin des départements
quel rôle va jouer la région quel rôle
doit gel doit jouer la métropole est
peut-être là encore que la solution qui
doit s'appliquer ne sera pas la même sur
l'ensemble du territoire national quand
vous avez des régions des très grandes
régions et il faut il faut lier ça
maintenant au redécoupage avec les 12
grandes régions françaises quand vous
avez des très grandes régions très vaste
je crois que le département a son
utilité parce que ça reste en échelon de
proximité et je crois aussi que en ile
de france il a encore son utilité moi je
pense que si il y à un échelon sur
lequel il faudrait avancer en
ile-de-france en tout cas pour ce qui
nous concerne c'est celui de la
métropole moi j'ai toujours été pour une
grande métropole régionale en tout cas
une région métropole parce que je crois
que finalement la région est en capacité
aujourd'hui d'avoir un périmètre plus
large dans ses compétences et finalement
reprendre ce que fait la métropole en
tout cas j'espère qu'un jour on pourra
ouvrir ce débat institutionnel mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit la priorité la
priorité en un mot et je le vois tous
les jours en tant que maire depuis mon
élection c'est d'être accompagné d'être
accompagné dans l'ingénierie d'être
accompagné dans les moyens et encore une
fois on a des moyens aujourd'hui qui
sont mis sur la table avec petite ville
de demain avec coeur de ville avec la
mct avec la dessine avec le plan de
relance avec demain avec le plan
d'investissement mais il faut qu'on
puisse répondre à ses appels à projets
donc il faut qu'on ait les ressources
humaines aussi un soutien humain pour
pouvoir le faire et dans la loi 3ds il
ya quelque chose avec mon père et ma qui
viendra compléter l'action de la société
mais on a aussi besoin de travailler
avec l'administration centrale encore
une fois aux critères moi je fais partie
de la strate des petites villes en tout
cas si on prend là la définition de la
définition des petites villes selon
l'association des petites villes de
france entre 2500 et 25000 habitants
mais la typologie de la commune de
villepreux et le fait que je sois une
commune petit mais dans une grande
agglomération
finalement je suis éligible à très peu
de dispositifs de l'état notamment
petite ville de demain je suis
malheureusement pas éligibles et donc
quand je reçois aujourd'hui le préfet
quand je reçois le délégué de l'agencé
nationale de cohésion des territoires et
que je lui montre mes projets et
j'essaye de faire en sorte que mes
projets puissent rentrer dans ses appels
à projets ont fait le constat finalement
que ma villepreux on est soit trop
petits soient trop grand on est trop
petit parce que on n'est pas quartiers
prioritaires on n'est pas quartier
politique de la ville on est trop grand
parce qu'on n'est pas commune rurale et
finalement on se rend compte que pour
cette strate là on rentre pas dans les
critères posés par l'état donc je crois
que c'est aussi sur ça qu'il faut
avancer pour qu'on puisse avoir
finalement une politique daley de l'aide
à l'investissement qui est essentiel
dans d'autres pays pour les
collectivités et pour toutes les
collectivités
j'aimerais qu'on parle à présent du
programme petite ville de demain à voile
est incarnée par la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires jacqueline
gourault et keanu qui appartient le
rappelle à votre parti politique le
modèle ce programme donc il a pour
objectif de rénover l'habitat maintenir
les commerces de proximité revoir
l'urbanisme et construire de nouveaux
équipements dans des villes de moins de
vingt mille habitants alors ces villes
ont besoin d'être soutenus
financièrement absolument et c'est un
beau programme c'est le programme que
nous demandions avec l'association des
petites villes de france qui a été
évidemment associés qui est partenaire
de ceux de ce dispositif et je salue
l'action de notre président christophe
bouillon maire de barentin ce
programme-là qui concerne 1600 commune
et qui a été dotée de 2 3 milliards
d'ailleurs avec une rallonge qui a
annoncé le premier ministre à l'occasion
de deux de nos assises on a été on était
rassemblée à cenon en début d'année du
côté de bordeaux 350 millions de plus
sur la des cils justement sur ce
programme également sur les contrats de
relance de transition écologique et sur
les grands dispositifs à destination
notamment des communes les plus urbaines
en faudra voir comment cette enveloppe
se répartit mais en tout cas on salue
l'effort oui ce dispositif et c'est
essentiel il permet encore une fois de
soutenir l'investissement et les projets
des communes de notre strate on parle de
re quel de requalification de village on
parle de service public de proximité on
parle de vidy de vie attractif en tout
cas de vie économique et c'est vrai que
on attendait ce programme là au début du
quinquennat on avait le programme coeur
de ville qui était vraiment axé sur des
communes de taille de taille supérieure
un peu plus urbaine et il manquait ce
set et chant là mais encore une fois
même si je soutiens à 100% ce dispositif
je crois qu'il demeure encore
aujourd'hui un parfait pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées précédemment
c'est une question critères une création
critères isation alors évidemment toutes
les communes ne peuvent pas être
éligibles parce qu'il faut que ça rentre
dans le cadre de l' enveloppe budgétaire
mais je crois qu'il ya encore des
efforts à faire et moi j'espère que
notamment sur les contrats de relance de
transition écologique qui sont des
outils je crois intéressant on puisse
avoir ce travail très fin entre les
collectivités et l'état est évidemment
le gouvernement pour que ces projets
puissent être accompagnés du mieux
possible et que encore une fois on
tienne compte des réalités locales parce
que encore une fois ma commune koch
pratiquement l'ensemble des critères
mais pour deux ou trois éléments je ne
suis pas éligibles à ces dispositifs
donc là je crois qu'il ya un travail
encore
à faire pour que ce dispositif
finalement arriva à répondre aux
préoccupations de l'ensemble des
communes de france dans l'actualité
politique on a appris cette semaine le
lancement d'un mouvement nommé ensemble
citoyens qui sera lancée donc dans les
prochaines semaines afin de pré prod de
préparer la campagne présidentielle et
surtout celle des législatives alors la
république en marche agir territoire de
progrès or horizons et enfin le modem
donc votre parti vont se coordonner pour
faire campagne donc ensemble citoyens
validerait donc c'est encore à définir
toutes les investitures pour les
législatives
alors aujourd'hui cette union elle est
primordiale dans la famille centriste
alors je pense qu'il faut parler avec
prudence parce que finalement c'est une
information qui est tout toute récente
et donc on n'a pas les on n'a pas les
contours on n'a pas le format il ya un
nom qui a été évoqué dans la presse mais
qui sur lequel pour l'instant moi j'ai
pas de d'un format de l'est pendant ce
mondial en revanche oui il ya ce besoin
de faire l'union avant l'élection
présidentielle il ya ce besoin de
rassembler les composantes de la
majorité présidentielle les composantes
historiques que sont la république en
marche et le modem et puis les nouveaux
venus je pense aux parties horizons
notamment qui est forte dans la pulsion
a été donnée par edouard philippe le
maire du havre et ancien premier
ministre et donc je crois que c'est très
bien finalement qu'on se rassemble on a
besoin d'arriver à cette présidentielle
unie avec un objectif commun qui est
celui de la réélection du président de
la république on verra quelle forme ça
prend de ce que je comprends c'est que
on est passé plutôt de l'idée de la
maison commune à l'idée d'une colocation
et je crois que c'est très bien parce
que finalement tout le monde va être
comment dire respecter dans son identité
donc il ya aussi une pluralité il ya du
pluralisme au sein de la de la majorité
présidentielle on n'a pas les mêmes
histoires on n'a pas les mêmes héritage
on n'a pas les mêmes parcours politique
il ya des centristes il ya des
progressistes ya des démocrates il ya
des personnes qui viennent de la droite
des personnes qui viennent de la gauche
et je crois que en tout cas faire
l'union et à voir je ne sais pas si
c'est une nouvelle structure je crois
pas qu'on parle de partis politiques
mais en tout cas un espace commun qui
puisse fédérer tout le monde je crois
que c'est une excellente idée en tout
cas c'est essentiel on va voir après
comment ça va se passer concrètement et
notamment sur sur le département et puis
quelque part
je crois que l'élection présidentielle
n'est pas uniquement la sphère des
parties et c'est pour ça que nous avons
lancé avec plusieurs maires dans les
yvelines des comités de soutien à
l'action et puis à la réélection du
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui sont vraiment des comités qui
se veulent nos partisans ou trans
partisan politique évidemment parce que
le terme à politique ne veut rien dire
ça veut dire que l'on ne fait pas de
politique donc évidemment qu'on fait de
la politique mais le fait de d'être
impulsée par des élus locaux qui ont la
confiance de leurs administrés ça nous
permet de rassembler plus largement et
de mettre les étiquettes partisanes
finalement deux côtés avec un objectif
faire réussir la france et nous nous
estimons que c'est le candidat afin que
le candidat idéal pour cela est
évidemment le président la république
avec ma croûte alors côté local pour
finir cette émission la préfecture des
yvelines a annoncé cette semaine que
l'état avait renoncé à vendre le domaine
de grignon au promoteur altarea cogedim
un lieu que les étudiants
d'agroparistech les chercheurs de
l'institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement occupe depuis deux
siècles alors peut-on dire que l'état a
écouté les élus locaux sur sur ce
dossier et je rappelle pour préciser que
grignon ci ne suis pas très loin de
votre ville de villepreux oui
effectivement en étaient concernés en
tout cas j'ai suivi ce dossier avec
grand intérêt et on la suit avec les
collègues notamment de l'association de
la plaine de versailles et je remercie
le maire de feucherolles et président de
notre association patrick loisel pour
son action qui nous a rassemblés il ya
peu on a d'ailleurs signé un courrier
commun les 27 communes ont signé un
courrier justement d'interpellations et
d'étonnement mais mais mais aussi dans
une démarche constructive pour trouver
des solutions avec l'état oui l'état
nous a écoutés je remercie le préfet
jean-jacques brot qui a été un artisan
de cette écoute en tout cas il faudra
voir comment les choses évoluent je
crois qu'on a besoin d'un temps de
concertation plus long et c'est ce qui a
manqué on a eu un projet
keep on ne faisait pas sans ce qui a été
un petit peu annoncé comme ça à la va
vite sans qu'on ait le temps d'inclure
les élus locaux dans la réflexion et
finalement les différents partenaires
locaux il ya eu aussi des sujets de
libertés locales parce que
notre collègue mr évidemment avec
quelques sujets d'articulation de ce
projet avec son père lui et je crois que
ce serait envoyer une très mauvaise
image et une dent dans le contexte
actuel qu'on ait évoqué tout à l'heure
avant tout cas ça aurait été très
négatif qui on est un projet urbain de
l'état qui s'impose en dépit des règles
et des réglementations locales et des
intérêts locaux donc en tout cas ce qui
a été annoncé néanmoins c'est que les
étudiants d'agroparistech prendront
possession de leur lieu sur paris saclay
à l'échéance prévue maintenant il va
falloir qu'on regarde quelles vont être
les évolutions pour le projet pour pour
pour le site en question on va continuer
à rester mobilisés mais toujours dans
une démarche constructive parce que je
crois que
quelque part c'est une main tendue de la
part du préfet de l'état sur ce sujet là
je le remercie on va être vigilant on va
être encore une fois exigeants sur le
devenir de ce dossier en tout cas les
les bases sont posées pour une
discussion merci beaucoup je remercie à
venir en terme d'avoir été avec nous
dans l'hebdo politique je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire modem de villepreux
et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo politique et en attendant très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique